bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
l'actu de ce vendredi 21 mars vous le
savez comme tous les jours nous allons
faire le point sur votre actualité
locale tout d'abord le dossier A4
technologique continue après leur
mouvement du des 14 et 28 février
dernier et surtout le silence de la
direction les salariés de l'entreprise
s'apprêtent à nouveau à manifester ce
vendredi devant le siège social de la
firme à Boulogne-Billancourt les
employés basés notamment à Guyancourt
protestent toujours contre la politique
de l'entreprise de modifier le barème de
remboursement de frais il perdent en
moyenne entre 300 et 900 euros par mois
selon les cas à noter K4 technologie a
fait état d'un chiffre d'affaires de 231
millions d'euros 4e trimestre 2013 en
repli d’un virgule 6% mais le groupe a
légèrement dépassé son objectif annuel
de 875 millions d'euros
du salarié l'idéal si vous voulez pour
nous c'est ça serait au frais
aujourd'hui puisque l'argumentation et
direction aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle veut
se mettre en conformité avec l'URS
aujourd'hui un salarié si le stage le
salarié justifie les 150 euros pour le
cercle aucun problème
puisque nous on dit si vraiment c'est de
se mettre au conformités
simplement tout ça un coup pour la
société parce qu'aujourd'hui en fin de
compte vraiment le nouveau barème c'est
vraiment une mesure d'économie
l'université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines semble sauver du moins à court
terme l'État a annoncé il y a quelques
jours qu'il verserait une avance
remboursable de 2,6 millions d'euros en
décembre dernier le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur avait déjà dû
verser 800000 euros c'est annonce est
tombé en même temps que le rapport de la
Cour des comptes qui couvre la période
2006 2012 et reprend des critiques déjà
émises lors de la découverte du déficit
du budget de l'UVSQ par exemple des
opérations de partenariat public privé
mal géré un recours excessif aux heures
supplémentaires ou encore une
augmentation mal maîtrisée des emplois
les lycéens avaient jusqu'à mercredi
pour compléter leur souhait post-bac les
questions sont souvent nombreuses
concernant la bonne orientation à
prendre dans les années futures des
réponses que peuvent apporter les
Conseillers d'Orientation Psychologue et
des sociétés de coaching privé
souhaitent aussi d'entrer dans ce
créneau exemple à Versailles Sabrina
sichkini
au niveau de l'orientation une formalité
pour les uns un casse-tête pour les
autres Sonia tarabal l'a bien compris il
y a un an cette ancienne salarié de
Saint-Gobain intitulée Dans capes
d'espagnol s'est lancé dans le coaching
d'orientation privée mon oriente les
élèves depuis la classe de 3e jusqu'à
jusqu'aux études supérieures l'avantage
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on permet aux
élèves d'accéder à beaucoup de domaines
d'études quel que soit leur filière de
formation la seule chose c'est qu'on
leur dit pas comment y accéder
correctement ou le ou le plus simplement
possible pour certains son bac en poche
Camille décide d'étudier la médiation
culturelle trois ans plus tard elle se
rend compte qu'elle s'est trompée elle
frappe alors à la porte du coach je suis
allée pour ce que j'avais un coup de
coeur et c'était une formation qui je
pensais pouvait me convenir mais en fait
on n'a pas aiguillé dans mes champs la
jeune femme souhaite désormais
s'orienter vers des études de graphisme
lors des entretiens avec sa conseillère
elle a été déroutée par le nombre de
formations possibles
tu mets la licence dans elle est en
terminale scientifique il y a un an elle
a des doutes quant à son avenir
professionnel lors des séances de
coaching elle confirme son appétence
pour le commerce aujourd'hui Sonia
taradement de ses vœux sur le site
admission post-bac
certaines familles trouvent leur compte
les Conseillers d'Orientation
Psychologue et mettent quelques réserves
quand tout développement du coaching
privé en ligne de mire la formation des
coachs
n'importe qui et en fait n'importe
quel est peu se nommer coach le problème
c'est que tout jeune ne peut pas
s'offrir les services d'un coaching
privé
en Sion ici à Versailles les tarifs du
coaching varient entre 330 et 580 euros
pour 4 heures d'entretien des sommes que
certains sont prêts à payer pour être
rassurés sur leur choix
le Solar Décathlon de Versailles a
annoncé le parrain de son édition 2014
il s'agit du navigateur vainqueur du
Vendée Globe Michel Desjoyaux un marin
depuis longtemps concernés par le
devenir de la planète Olivier Maniscalco
et Jonathan Wilman
vous allez me dire le parallèle entre
les bateaux à voile et solars Decathlon
ben en fait sur un bateau à voile à
fortiori en compétition on est très
économe en énergie
Michel Desjoyaux parrain du Solar
Décathlon Europe de Versailles c'est
l'heure d'un point presse le 17 mars au
ministère de l'Égalité des territoires
et du logement que l'annonce a été
officialisée compétition internationale
d'architecture environnementale le Solar
et l'IRA en juillet prochain le meilleur
projet étudiant de maison alimenté en
énergie solaire le navigateur
finistérien double vainqueur du Vendée
Globe a tout de suite adhéré au projet
et apportera outre sa notoriété une
conscience écologique qui ne date pas
d'hier moi j'ai tout de suite embrayé
sur la proposition
à titre perso tout simplement parce que
moi je suis passionné de technologie
d'innovation de compétition aussi mais
je suis aussi tout simplement citoyen
mais deux dernières maisons sont
équipés de panneaux solaires thermiques
même en Bretagne assez de soleil pour
chauffer de l'eau
ant et mis d'énergie et utiliser les
énergies renouvelables dans le bâtiment
et puis de montrer aussi toutes les
inventions toutes les innovations qui
sont en cours dans secteur c'est c'est
une bonne manière de montrer
effectivement qu'on est plus seulement
dans l'innovation innovation en train de
de découler dans dans nos réalisations
concrètes et c'est nécessaire parce que
la transition énergétique c'est vraiment
le challenge du 21e siècle de notre
continent et donc de notre pays
lors de ce solar Décathlon Europe de
projets français seront présentés en
2012 lors de la dernière édition c'est
un prototype grenoblois qu'il l'avait
emporté
si vous possédez votre carte d'électeur
vous le savez vous êtes appelé aux yeux
en ce dimanche 23 mars pour le premier
tour des élections municipales vous
voterez donc pour vos conseillers
municipaux comme d'habitude mes
nouveautés cette année également pour
vos conseillers communautaires mode
d'emploi avec Catherine dulato
du nouveau pour les électeurs lors de
ces élections municipales dont le
premier tour se déroule le 23 mars ils
voteront bien évidemment pour une liste
de conseillers municipaux mais également
pour choisir ceux qui siégeront au sein
des agglomérations les conseillers
communautaires étaient auparavant élus
par leur père ils le seront maintenant
au suffrage universel direct en
conséquence dimanche les électeurs
verront apparaître sur un même et seul
butin au format paysage de liste une
liste de conseillers municipaux et une
liste de conseillers communautaires les
listes ne pourront pas être séparées et
vous ne pourrez pas rayer de noms par
exemple à Montigny-le-Bretonneux les
électeurs auront le choix entre trois
listes de candidats chaque liste
comprendra 39 noms de conseillers
municipaux et parmi ces 39 noms 13 ont
été choisis pour être proposés comme
conseiller communautaire c'est de liste
seront paritaires un homme une femme un
homme une femme etc à 50 ans en Yvelines
il y a donc 48 conseillers
communautaires à élire rép Artis en
fonction de la taille démographique des
villes un nouveau scrutin qui change
bien la donne car le nombre de
conseillers communautaires siégeant par
commune à l'agglomération dépendra
demain du résultat réalisé par chaque
liste c'est le principe du scrutin
proportionnel dans les Yvelines pour ces
élections il y a 5310 conseillers
municipaux à élire et 737 conseillers
communautaires au suffrage universel
direct
il y a 15 jours cet homme est entré dans
la légende du cyclisme sur piste le
nouvel ini-montin François Pervis a
décroché trois titres de champion du
monde rien que ça en Kirin sur le
kilomètre et sur la vitesse individuelle
il signala un triplet historique et
inédit jamais personne n'avait réalisé
une telle performance dans un même
championnat du monde de retour de
Colombie François Pervis nous a accordé
une interview vérité et est revenue sur
son exploit
trois médaille d'or c'est un triplé
unique puisque je suis le premier de
l'histoire de mon sport à gagner les
trois épreuves individuelles donc
j'avais annoncé avant de partir c'était
mon objectif j'ai réussi à le faire et
ça peut être une chose simple forcément
et bah c'est forcément je suis super
content
et vous pourrez retrouver évidemment
l'intégralité de cette entretien dans le
prochain 7 8 sport lundi à 18h30 c'est
la fin de cette édition merci encore une
fois de l'avoir suivi pour toutes vos
idées de sortie vous retrouvez la
charmante Yolaine Torres pour le 7 8
weekends quant à moi je vous souhaite
une excellente fin de journée sur TV
fils